flight numbers there's something we only
usually remember for those few moments
when we're looking for our gate at the
airport but this year to flight numbers
have become tragically ingrained in our
minds on Saturday March the eighth
flight mh370 disappeared from radar
shortly after takeoff from kuala lumper
239 people were on board the plane has
never been found the agony on the faces
of the relatives was horrendous in kuala
lumper they tried to ambush government
ministers in a truly desperate search
for answers in China where most of the
passengers were from the relatives
gathered at a Beijing hotel daily they
were updated on progress there was no
and they grew ever more convinced of a
conspiracy all of them are still waiting
for answers defying belief four months
later on July the 17th another Malaysia
Airlines plane came down mh17 298 people
victims of a war which had nothing to do
with them sometimes during the course of
our work we meet people whose lives and
stories are truly astonishing in Seoul
South Korea this year we met a woman who
I will never forget in graphic detail
she told us of her life in a North
Korean prison camp Goodison an
interrogation cruel Morton Kamen more
gin up America makati cucamonga chaga
ceramic eroding cambogia new go salami
and American or ki kahani yoga cosas que
que no quiero que c'mon Cyril Kirk ain't
a [ __ ] Caren campano container bala
nagar eaten companion ozone air attack
on America and hasta maana caldera
natsuko khoya p.o some tomalak a zogo
curry tonika e bo Dietl cote de la mode
ET homological the texan was arrested
cincin barato Tom nario seemed somewhat
Haram is haraam erotic rookie its
testimony like that which has made the
issue of North Korea's human rights be
raised right at the top of the United
Nations perhaps there will be some
change within North Korea one human
gumbo we spend a lot of time this year
as well in Hong Kong pro-democracy
protesters who posed the greatest
challenge to Chinese rule since the
handover from Britain in 1997 on the
face of it the protesters have
comprehensively failed none of their
demands have been met and they were
cleared on a few weeks ago but look at
how young those protesters are they're
all four corners they're not going
anywhere they've certainly given their
message to Beijing and I've little doubt
that they will be back